o iPhone wallpaper plena Ponte Estaiada
leite eu vou ver ele é
e a filantropia ajudar pessoas realmente
mudou a minha vida aqui tá uma foto
minha com dois anos de idade você foi
uma criança muito alegre muito feliz
último educação muito rígida com meus
pais mas na sala de aula era aquela
pessoa que tinha facilidade e fazer todo
mundo rir o famoso palhaço de turma
cresci sempre gostei muito de estudar
fiz faculdade duas pós vários que os a
partir de inteligência emocional e
também uma formação internacional em
coaching na metade da vida profissional
Quando entrei para área comercial eu
nunca mais sair eu sempre gostei muito
de conhecer novas pessoas fazer novas
amizades essa é uma coisa que realmente
me realiza mas eu tinha um sonho que era
me tornar um palhaço de hospital
e eu sempre olhava esses palhaços nas
redes sociais e eu tinha muita admiração
muito carinho por eles mas eu olhava
assim como algo praticamente impossível
muito longe de mim eu consegui eu me
tornar um mas em 2016 eu tomei muita
coragem e me inscrevi projeto chamado
hospirrisos aqui de Joinville onde foram
cerca de dois meses e realizando aulas
de teatro para criar o personagem de
dentro para fora para que ele fosse
verdadeiro e conseguisse lidar com os
bastidores de um hospital então surgiu o
Vitorino Fitness o atleta campeão
mundial de várias modalidades aqui tá
uma foto dele eu coloquei seis medalhas
no meu peito e a gente sempre tem acesso
a ver crianças a ver jovens haver idosos
Geralmente eu tô com mais um ou dois
palhaços e quando eu tô com as crianças
eu chego no quarto dizendo que eu sou
campeão mundial de obedecer a minha mãe
Ah e outra medalha é que eu sou o
campeão mundial de lavar louça pra mãe e
eu pergunto se a criança faz isso então
as mães elas me adoram ela sempre falam
Escuta esse palhacinho meu filho e se a
criança não faça eu já vou lá e
repreendo ela você tem que fazer você
tem que obedecer seu pai a sua mãe então
é sempre muito divertido outra medalha
os campeão mundial de fazer bolinhas de
sabão onde eu faço a interagem com todo
mundo que tá no quarto paciente
visitante outra medalha é um malabarismo
eu faço uma laborista diferente com 3
bolinhas algo assim qo pessoal fica
espantado com a minha habilidade e
ninguém espera isso então é realmente
muito engraçado e outra medalha é
campeão mundial de fazer animais
e eu fazer um agora para vocês
e eu sempre dou três opções Então eu
tenho um cachorrinho normal aí eu tenho
um cachorrinho Basset só que o Buzz e
limousine alongado é o maior bacia que
Vocês poderiam ver e também a girafa mas
vou fazer agora para vocês o cachorrinho
normal esse é o normal eu aprendi a
fazer isso aqui olhando o YouTube não
comente não sairá praticamente nada e
é mas depois conseguir aprender
O que é muito bom assim ver o carinho os
pacientes que os pacientes têm toda a
gente deixa esse cachorrinho ou a girafa
e aqui tá o cachorrinho
Oi e eu sempre falo que o cachorrinho
ele come apenas duas coisas
é a primeira picanha a segunda palmito e
eu sempre falo para os pacientes daqui a
primeira vez eles tem que me convidar
para realmente eu ir lá ver se tá tudo
de acordo se aquela picanha prêmio vende
no máximo 900 gramas 1 kg e aquele
palmito bem molinho naquele momento que
só que a gengiva Você já consegue
mastigar ele é até hoje ninguém me
convidou mais uma hora eu tenho certeza
que vai dar certo
Vê se não parece do hospital foi uma das
coisas mais assertivas que eu fiz eu
tenho muito orgulho de ser eu aprendi
muito nos hospitais e e no começo eu não
conseguia entender por que que eu por
que que eu saía é tão renovado tão feliz
que o sentimento de gratidão assim nas
alturas e depois de meses realmente eu
consegui entender e isso fez um total
sentido para mim como todo na fila na
filantropia que é o seguinte quando você
ajuda uma pessoa na verdade que tá sendo
ajudado é você
e o diversas vezes eu vi assim como irem
às vezes é um ser humano falho de às
vezes reclamar de alguma coisa de achar
que tinha um problema e na verdade não
tinha é foram fardo sei que eu tirei das
minhas costas e a vida ficou muito mais
fácil muito mais tranquila e foram
vários relatos de alguns pacientes é
falaram né que não não cuidavam às vezes
a sua família não cuidavam muito da sua
saúde e quando eles saíssem de lá ia ser
diferente aí então realmente é ninguém
quer tá dentro do hospital é um momento
assim que o ser humano realmente tá
muito frágil né e todo mundo que pode
realmente tem que ir lá ajudar a fazer
alguma coisa aí então é uma coisa que os
lugares como mais gosta de estar sem
sombra de dúvida é dentro do hospital
Essa é a minha Essência lá realmente a
minha melhor versão e a um trabalho que
eu nunca vou deixar de fazer
infelizmente agora a gente está proibido
de nos hospitais são da da convide Mas
você que isso tudo uma hora vai passar e
a gente vai voltar aí a levar alegria e
amor para os pacientes Eu também quero
falar de outro trabalho social e se
envolve um grupo de amigos que eu tenho
há mais de 20 anos tudo começou em 2008
quando deles iria perder o carro porque
tava desempregado e a gente pensou vamos
ajudar Vamos fazer um carreteiro
beneficente entre nós mesmos e vão ver
se ele consegue cada algum valor e deu
muito certo a gente conseguiu adiantar
três parcelas do carro ele não perdeu e
a gente viu que realmente foi um dia
muito especial neste reunir os amigos e
ainda fez o bem e decidimos continuar
fazendo E lá se foram 13 anos onde a
gente ajudou várias pessoas várias
instituições
o evento começou a ser nenhuma pretensão
para 10 pessoas resultou no nosso último
para mais de mil e cem só não de 2019
tinha ficado mais de 100 mil reais e
esse valor foi sem por cento do lado o
nosso Estatuto da associação b157 da
Previ ncio que nem o mesmo fica com nada
de dinheiro ou seja um trabalho 100%
voluntário eu queria deixar aqui Meus
parabéns ao Pedro Adolfo que é o
presidente da associação uma pessoa que
nunca deixou a peteca cair um membro
ativo o nosso grande Pilar aí que esse
sucesso se deve muito a ele ao conselho
e a todo mundo aí que ajuda a associação
b157 aqui na cidade de Joinville é
fizemos também a primeira estramite do
bem no mercado público nesse raminho 28
instituições onde ela se o cada uma
barraquinha vendendo comida é ou roupa e
nesse dia foi menor me sucesso passou
mais esse
Oi e essa festa entrou para o calendário
de Joinville venha poderia a gente não
conseguiu fazer mais os eventos
presenciais mas que uma campanha online
de arrecadação de cesta básica e a gente
conseguiu arrecadar mais de 15 toneladas
e nas entregas é difícil não se
emocionar porque você vê famílias e além
que às vezes não têm o que comer e às
vezes eu vejo né a gente faz tão
pouquinho mas por outro lado é muito
realmente é muito e e não custa nada a
gente realmente ajudar o próximo fizemos
também dois carreteiro drive thru deu
muito certo e esse ano a gente vai
continuar fazendo outros eventos aí a
previsão é fazer em torno de três a
quatro eventos a gente tá vendo como é
que vai ficar a situação da cor vídeo
ainda
e eu não tô aqui para me vangloriar de
nada é essa Associação ela não é minha
ela mais de nenhum lembro ela é de um
canal lá de cima que nos conduz sempre
da melhor forma possível Eu sempre tive
várias pessoas que realmente me me
estimularam na parte da filantropia como
meus amigos não tenho vários amigos ali
da própria Associação que me servem de
inspiração pessoas como também Madre
Tereza de calcutar Irmã Dulce Mandela
Martin Luther King São pessoas que
realmente fizeram a diferença no mundo e
ela sempre levaram uma coisa de mesmo
lugar que é o amor o amor ele ele tem um
poder assim inestimável de cura de
perdoar de não julgar ninguém
a e é isso que esse mundo precisa e eu
tenho certeza que se cada um fizesse
apenas um pouquinho a gente teria um
mundo muito melhor e acabaria com a
miséria aí do planeta
e eu vou deixar uma frase que realmente
já me acompanha há muito tempo que me
inspira ser um ser humano melhor que é
da magreza de facultar que ela disse sei
que meu trabalho é uma gota no oceano
mas sem ele o oceano seria menor